[Musique]
durant des milliers d'années
le lien entre mes enfants et moi était
parfait aujourd'hui d'une présence
obscur menace de détruire l'amazonie je
suis ngô de kandani la chose la plus
géniale de tout acabit
et nouveau tué une petite fille
exceptionnelle qui a été désigné par les
esprits salut toi on est désespérés
qu'ils mois cédilot et moins encore 7
mois descendre situationniste ses doigts
qui doit sauver les vidanges
il faut que tu sois forte nous devons
les sharks et saufs condamné
et les temps porno d'être courageux bull
courage
c'est magnifique et doit croire très
fort en toi même prêt à vous envoler
oh
[Applaudissements]
ça fait cent ans que je n'ai vu personne
[Musique]
ce matin l'or